la frontera entre Israel y gaza fue de
nuevo escenario de un intercambio de
fuego motivado por la letal redada
israelí en la blues que causó la muerte
de 11 palestinos en una aparente
respuesta y durante la madrugada desde
la franja se lanzaron seis cohetes hacia
ciudades del sur israelí sin
consecuencias porque cinco Fueron
interceptados por la cúpula de hierro y
uno cayó en zonas despobladas luego
Israel atacó con aviones de combate y
destruyó lo que según el ejército era un
centro de fabricación de armas de jamás
y también un complejo militar para
intentar calmar los ánimos el enviado de
la ONU en medio oriente Thor westland ha
viajado a gaza para reunirse con líderes
de jamás y reforzar la mediación que
lleva a cabo Egipto Y es que la
operación israelí para capturar a
milicianos en naluse que fue a plena luz
del día y en una zona muy poblada ha
sido la más mortífera en sí Jordania
desde 2005 cuando la ONU comenzó su
recuento y ha dejado al menos cinco
civiles fallecidos el último un hombre
de 66 años que murió en la noche por
complicaciones respiratorias debido a
los gases lacrimógenos lanzados por los
soldados israelíes Como protesta hoy se
observa una huelga general en los
territorios palestinos con cierre de
comercios escuelas y bancos además el
alto número de heridos en la redada que
superó el centenar también despertó una
inusual respuesta internacional Estados
Unidos se mostró muy preocupado por esto
y porque la redada puede hacer
contraproducente mientras que tanto
Francia como Alemania recordaron que el
uso de la fuerza debe ser proporcional y
que la población civil debe ser
protegida